okay in this session we're going to look
at the support vector machine and we're
going to do it again in rstudio using
the markdown script as before
we're going to depart a little bit from
the r code in in this chapter in that
i'm going to be showing you uh two
examples of of using the support vector
machine
both in two dimensions and i'm going to
focus on producing uh plots of the
result and and so you can see how to to
make nice pictures like the ones we do
in the book
um and
in the book um there's examples of how
you use cross validation to select the
cost parameters and so on and but we
won't do that in the session today
okay so we're going to generate some
data
and
we'll make a matrix x
we'll make
20 observations
in in two classes on two variables so
that's
used we use the matrix command and we
make them normally distributed
and then we make a y variable which is
going to be minus one or plus one
[Music]
and there's
10 in each class
and then
for the y equal plus 1 guys we move
their
their means from 0 to to 1 in each of
the coordinates
so that's what we've done there now we
plot the data and we color code the
points according to the response
and there's a simple way of doing it and
noticed i used
the plotting character 19 again because
that gives us that nice big visible
dot
coded blue or red according to whether
the response is plus one or minus one
okay so those are our data
now the svm function that we use is in
the package e1071
which is a room number in
in the universe technical university in
berlin
where a lot of this code was developed
so we'll
we'll load that library
of course you have to have it installed
but it's easy to install these libraries
and
now we'll make a data frame of our data
and
svm we're going to turn y into a factor
variable here
and and so that's done in in that
command and now we make a call to svm
so it uses the formula language just
like in our other example so we go y
twiddle dot
why is the response and the other
variables are the the predictors
the data frame will have unpacked the
matrix x into two columns named x1 and
x2
and we tell svm that the kernel is
linear because we want to fit a support
vector classifier which is a linear
classifier in this case later on we'll
do a radial kernel
and the tuning parameter is the cost
which we'll set at 10
and scale equals false for this for this
example we'll ask it not to standardize
the variables
and there we've done the fit
and now we can print it and you get a
little summary of of the fit doesn't
tell you too much
except that it does say the number of
support vectors is 6.
so remember in class the support vectors
are the points that are close to the
boundary or on the wrong side of the
boundary
now there is a plot function for the
support vector machines but i would say
it's not a particularly nice plot
function
it's it shows you it
it shows you the decision boundary it
looks a little bit jagged here
it doesn't seem there's much control
over the colors and
as we point out in the book
it breaks with convention and it puts x2
on the horizontal axis and x1 on the
vertical axis
but it's there and it's it's you can you
can get a quick plot
[Music]
if you want but we i'm going to show you
how you can make your plot on your own
and what we're going to do
is the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to make a grid of values or
lattice of values for x1 and x2 that
covers the whole domain
on a fairly fine lattice and then we're
going to produce the classifier we're
going to predict the classified each
point in the lattice
and and then color code
the
plot them and color code the points so
we can actually see the decision
boundary
and so there's some text that tells you
about what we're going to do
and
let's just get to the code you can read
the text
later
so first of all we're going to make a
function called make dot grid and it's
going to take in our data matrix x and
it takes an argument in the number of
points in each direction
and we're going to ask for 75. so we're
going to ask for a 75 by 75
grid
okay and this function make dot grid is
going to do it so make dot grid so
i'll enter it now so
the first thing it does is it uses the
apply function to get the range of each
of the variables in x
okay and then for each of them x1 and x2
it uses the seek function to go from
the the lowest value to the upper value
and and make a grid of length n so it's
very simple
and then now it's got these x1 and x2
now um are each of length 75 uniformly
spaced
values on each of the coordinates and
then there's this wonderful function
called expand.grid which takes those two
and makes a
makes the lattice for you
okay and and then that's what gets
returned so let's apply it x grid gets
make dot grid of x and before we we
actually go into our prediction let me
just go down here and let's look at x
squared
let's look at the first the first few
values so 1
2 to 10.
and so you can see there's the the grid
starting so it's it's it's going through
the first coordinate first holding the
second coordinate fixed
and it'll be 75 times 75 so
so that's 5 625 points are going to be
on this grid okay but it's done that for
you
so back to our code we now predict from
our svm fit at the values on this grid
so the new data we're given it is x grid
and we call the response y grid
so now what i'm going to do is make a
plot and i plot all the points in x grid
and i color them according to what their
prediction was
and there it is
and so now you actually see the decision
boundaries so each of those you see the
fine lattice say each of the points
is
um is one of the points on the lattice
and we've
we've color-coded where they classify so
you can clearly see the decision
boundary
and we'll put our original points on
this plot
and there they are
and so now you can see which ones are
close to the boundary and in fact
on the svm foot
is a component called index and that
actually tells you which are the support
points so we're going to include them in
the plot
by using the points function
and as a slightly different plot in
character and we made it cx equals 2
that's carrick expansion is 2 to make
this these plotting symbols a bit bigger
so that we can clear clearly see them on
the plot and as i as i i promised these
are close to the decision boundary so
these are the points that were actually
instrumental in in determining the
decision boundary
okay so that's using our linear support
vector machine in two dimensions
the function
svm is i do not think that user friendly
and one of the things
you don't easily get from it are the
coefficients
that one would use
to describe the linear function
they code they they can be derived from
the objects on the foot
but
we're going to have to do that ourself
so that's not really described in this
book but there's chapter 12 of elements
of statistical learning which is our
earlier textbook more advanced textbook
and if you look in chapter 12 you'll see
how to do what i'm about to do here and
we've just written some code to do that
so this is to extract the linear
coefficients that describe that linear
boundary
and so i'm going to just go through the
steps here and do that
and
and so
that i extracted beta and beta0
which used the formulas described in
that chapter
so now i'll replot my points on the grid
i'll put my my
my points back in and and the support
vector machines um
the the support points and now i'm going
to use the coefficients
to draw the decision boundary
so this will
it's a simple equation the the the
equations of the form beta 0 plus beta 1
x 1 plus beta 2 x 2 equals 0. and from
that equation you have to figure out a
slope and an intercept for the decision
boundary
so it's a little bit of algebra it's not
too hard
and
when once you do that you can use the
function a b line a b line
is expects an intercept and a slope
and you can see it we've got it spot on
there's a decision boundary and now we
can put in the margins as well
and i'll put in the upper margin and the
lower margin
and so that's very nice you see that
that some of the support points are
exactly on the margin
and and some of the others are
inside the margin
and so there we're done with the linear
support vector machine we've seen how to
extract the coefficients
and we've seen how to produce the
pictures like pictures that we have in
the book